Hi. I am B.L. Garrett. I’m a documentary
filmmaker. I make films on ordinary, average,
everyday people. Everybody’s got a story.
I got into filmmaking about three and a half
year’s ago. I wanted to make a film on my
88-year old grandfather. He grew up poor
on a farm in Oklahoma. His father was a sharecropper.
He served in World War II and in the South
Pacific. Later he went on to start his own
business and have a successful career. He
is really a modern-day John Wayne. I knew
nothing about filmmaking and really all my
resources came from YouTube which is kind
of a scary thought. There’s so much information
out there and I spent hundreds and hundreds
of hours researching cameras, lighting, audio,
tripods, monopods, shotgun mics, lavalier
mics, recorders. I mean you name it. So
today I’m gonna talk about the equipment
that I that I landed on and how it’s worked
for me and the strengths and some of the weaknesses
of my equipment. The first thing I’ll talk
about is my camera. I landed on a Panasonic
gh3. At the time the gh2 was still out and
kind of all the rage. You could go on Vimeo,
YouTube, I mean I would see this beautiful
footage of hacked gh2a and I was amazed by
really how small the camera was and that intrigued
me. I thought to get footage like that it
had to be this big, bulky camera that sat
on your shoulder and I was just unaware that
a DSLR type camera could do something like
that. I ended up going with the gh3 for a
couple of reasons. The main reason was battery
life. I can literally on one battery use my
gh3 for almost five hours. Another thing that
I like about my gh3 is that I can put a hundred
and twenty eight gig sd card in and film at
50 megabits per second for five and a half
hours, which is remarkable. So I always
have two hundred and twenty eight gig cards
on me. I have two batteries on me so if
I ever go out to a shoot, say I have a subject
I’m making a film on and I go out and I
have an eight hour day, I can film all day
with those two batteries and really one sd
card (to tell you the truth). I go to the
other sd card, but you know usually the one
sd card gets me through the day. Some of the
things I really like about the gh3 is that
it will film in 60 frames-per-second, 30 frames-per-second,
and 24 frames-per-second. I usually use 24
frames-per-second. It builds up to 72 megabits-per-second,
but I usually use the 50 megabits-per-second
and 24 frames-per-second and it really gives
me the 1080p HD-quality that I’m looking
for. I also love the LCD screen in the back.
It flips out. It swivels, so whenever I’m
interviewing somebody and I’m sitting next
to the camera, I can pull the LCD screen out
sideways and I can monitor the footage to
make sure that we’re still recording and
to make sure that we’re in focus. That’s
a huge thing. It’s got a HDMI output that
I love and it’s also got real time audio
jack where I can plug headphones in and listen
to the in-camera audio. Audio wise, I use
two zoom h1 recorders. I use two lavalier
mics that are made by Giant Squid. This
is really a great bargain. If you’re just
getting into filmmaking, there’s a lot of
recorders out there that I’m sure are much
better quality. But if you’re just getting
into filmmaking and you want to step up your
game to have something better than your in-camera
audio, I highly recommend the zoom H1. They
cost $99 a piece and the Giant Squid lavalier
mics cost $50. So basically two audio recorders
and two lavalier mics for $300 is a great
bargain. I also have a Rode video mic pro
shotgun mic that I mount on the hot shoe on
top of the gh3 camera. I use that really to
sink the audio with the recorded sound that
I get from the recorders and the lavalier
mic. I also use it for B-roll footage for
background noise and kind of chatter.
It works out great the gh3 is great because
the Micro Four Thirds cameras. It looks
like a still camera, like just a regular picture
camera and it’s really great when I’m
out in public. I’m getting B-roll footage.
People think that I’m taking pictures. They
don’t know that I’m getting the footage
from this little powerhouse.
A lot of times friends and family that have
seen a lot of my stuff, I’ll be out and
I’ll have my camera and they’ll be like
“what camera do you use when you make your
films?” And I’m like “This camera right
here and it’s really amazing, the footage
I get from it. It doesn’t shoot 4K, but
I don’t really need 4K yet, you know. I
am looking to upgrade in the next six months
or so. I might go to the Panasonic gh4.
I can tell you right now I looked on B&H Photo
and you can buy a brand new gh3 for $549 and
I’m seriously considering going that way.
I always, always, always – when I have a
job, I always ran an additional camera.
Usually the Panasonic gh3 I use LensRental.com.
They’ve done me right. I’ve used them
probably two dozen times. They always ship
it on time. It’s my same camera. I have
the lenses for it. I always have that for
a backup and I’ve used one for a wide angle
shot and a close-up shot for my films. So
if one fails me, I’ve got the backup.
Let’s talk about lenses. When I first
got the camera, something that I had learned
from the DrewNetwork, he talked about these
iconic lenses that were made in the eighties
by Nikkor. So I bought a 28 mm, f/2.8 AIS
and I bought a Nikkor 50 mm f/1.8. These
lenses were made in the early eighties and
it’s some of the some of the greatest glass
I’ve ever seen. Cool thing about it is
I buy all my lenses used at Keh.com and
these things we’re not that expensive. I
think for the two lenses I spent almost $300.
So those were my first two lenses. I also
purchased a 14 mm Panasonic pancake lens.
I believe it’s a f/2.5. So that was my
wide angle and it had autofocus, which is
nice when you’re shooting B roll and you’re
following somebody trying to do some Steadicam
work with your wide angle. It was really a
nice piece to my collection. But all my
early films, I used the 50 mm and the 28 mm
to interview my subjects and all my filming
was pretty much done with that. I’ve added
two more lenses to my collection since then.
Last year I purchased an Olympus 45mm and
it’s an F 1.8 and it is a beautiful portrait
lens for taking pictures and for filming.
This is one of my favorite lenses and I bought
it I think for $250 brand new on Amazon.
I think it was an international version and
you didn’t get a warranty with it but…
you know I’ll roll the dice on that to save
a hundred bucks. Secondly my last lens and
my most favorite lens is the Panasonic 12
to 35mm. That’s what I’m filming myself
on right now with my Panasonic gh3. It’s
got auto focus and it’s got on-board stabilization.
Griffin Hammond made a documentary called
Sriracha and he made the whole documentary
with my Panasonic gh3 and a Panasonic 12 to
35mm. I was blown away with the clarity, how
it looked and I wanted to have one at the
time, it was like $1,200. I couldn’t afford
that so I waited a year and a half and I just
bought one without the warranty on Amazon
for $765. It’s been a great addition.
It’s nice when I interview somebody…I
mean the worst thing ever is interviewing
somebody for an hour and a half and then going
home to edit and you pull up the footage and
it’s soft. It’s just soft enough where
you’re like “I just can’t use this footage.”
It looked great when I focused in on him,
but it was soft. So with the new lens, I
don’t have to worry about that with a 45mm
or the 12 to 35mm. The Panasonic gh3 has
a two-time crop factor so my 45mm really is
a 90mm and the 12-35 comes out to 24 to 70mm
focal length. Price was really a major factor
in purchasing the used Panasonic gh3 from
Keh.com. I believe I bought it for $800 used.
One thing about Keh.com is that how they market
the condition of the equipment is like no
other. If it says “like new” I mean
it is brand new. It can say “excellent”
all the way down to “bargain.” I have
friends who have bought bargain lenses and
there was nothing wrong with them (they were
great). One thing I want to mention today
about the company’s I’m talking about
that I’ve done business with, in no way
am I paid by these companies. I’m just a
satisfied customer and believe me, you can
check my bank account (it’s not that big).
Thank you guys SO much for watching. If
you ever have any questions, you can contact
me directly at BL@BLGarrettFilms.com. Have
a great day!